I want to talk about uh Mr Beast and
Hassan because we had the story
the other day we didn't get into Mr
Beast cured I think it was a thousand
people's cat uh cataract blindness yeah
with uh surgery and uh Hassan got
a bunch of what is this 24.8 million
views are you kidding holy crap look at
this that's on Hassan's one so this
tweak at 24.8 million views the video
was played six point eight million times
and it says twitch streamer Hassan
explained why he was filled with rage
from watching Mr BEAST's newest video
where he cures a thousand people's uh
blindness so let's play this it's only
45 seconds long and uh I I think it's an
important point
okay
you watch this video go oh how how cute
and how nice I watched the video and I'm
filled with rage
along with you that we shut off access
to a 10 minute procedure because we pay
walled it and decided that like some
people just simply can't get it
it is so insanely frustrating that it
like it's up to like one YouTube guy to
like decide to make content out of it
like is it people who are too poor can't
just see that's insane anyway
sorry it's just like a deeply deeply
frustrating concept he's 80 right we
didn't we didn't cut off access to
cataract search it just costs money and
he is right though that it's up to some
YouTube guy to make content out of it to
give these people the surgery they need
but you know what a lot of people were
ragging on them uh saying like he just
discovered what charity is and things
like that and I'm like as long as we are
giving a hundred billion dollars to
Ukraine I'm with this guy that hundred
billion dollars could be used to cure
blindness of American citizens who are
living in America in a country that
we're supposed like that is US literally
us so while I don't agree with him on
like it's paywall we should just do it
it's like well look you got to pay a guy
to do it you know he's got to be cut you
gotta cover his his costs and everything
he's got a incentivize me and slay them
but uh how much money did we send to
Ukraine 108 billion dollars so how much
money this got 10 10
000 or 10 million dollars for uh if that
how much you think it costs for uh this
surgery to cure cataracts
10 grand is a good guess I'm checking it
out now so we're talking 10 million
dollars yeah just 10 million bucks plus
maybe a little bit more if he's housing
them or flying them out or whatever but
like right bringing them in but maybe
it's not 10 grand for this surgery maybe
it's four or five yeah and I'm just
sitting here thinking like well you know
I don't think we should just take
people's buying power through taxation
or through printing of money to then
give someone else some kind of medical
treatment so I probably disagree with
Hassan on that one but look if if if
we're in a country that's sending all
this money overseas for like gender
studies programs imagine if instead of
Pakistani gender studies programs we
were like we're gonna we're gonna cure
about people's blindness reinvest so I
got I gotta agree it's kind of annoying
that some YouTube guy to make content
out of it for these people to actually
get the treatment they need meanwhile
they don't fix our streets they don't
fix our bridges
um here's what I'm saying I'm not
necessarily saying that we should have
taxation to fund this infrastructure or
No Deal I'm saying so long as they're
taking all of our money let's compromise
and be like spend it on us fix our
bridges fix our roads get create create
jobs and construction that can restore
our infrastructure secure our borders
bring bring manufacturing plants back
here instead it's war in Ukraine a
border country in which we are not on
the border of and then our people are
blind and the YouTube guys got to clear
gotta clip their eyes he also gave
people 50 Grand a bunch of them and one
guy he gave a new Tesla because he had
never been able to drive I saw this the
video is great you guys should watch
this we haven't seen it and he's like
when I get my eyes fixed I'm gonna get a
car and drive like that was his dream
and Miss Jimmy Mr Beast Jimmy Davidson I
think it's Jimmy Davis Donaldson
Donaldson Jimmy Donaldson I mean what a
guy he bought him a Tesla he's like
crazy and here's your Tesla pop culture
covered this today pop culture crisis uh
and they the Hassan thing or the the the
Mr Beast uh covers this because a bunch
of people on Twitter were like well he's
the Antichrist like who is he to cure
blindness I'm gonna be like what like
give this guy a break like I I
understand the objection that he has and
I totally agree with you like if we're
spending billions of dollars on Ukraine
it's hard not to be an American citizen
and be like we have problems that if
you're going to spend this money you
should spend it domestically but I also
think like we shouldn't at all make this
uh Mr B's fault right like he tried to
do a nice thing he has a lot of money
and he's trying to help people like and
don't frame it as Jimmy cured their
blindness the guy the people cured their
own blindness with the help of medical
technology that Jimmy sponsored that's
the story he didn't he wasn't like Jesus
hands on people which he probably could
have done but he made a ton of money
because of it yeah oh yeah the revenue
on that is probably insane and just the
pr is priceless that's the that's the
thing nobody you know nobody ever thinks
about is a PR in charity is amazing and
you know there's no there's no better
return on investment when it comes to
advertising what
I was talking about this earlier imagine
if imagine if big corporations did
things like this for marketing their
whole thing was we got a 50 million
marketing budget this month I know let's
do the most good possible because it'll
generate attention imagine if Pepsi was
like I know how to get the best most
viral look at this remember the
commercial they did with that General
lady and she like walks with a cop and
hands them a Pepsi oh yeah think about
how much money they spend on that and
how it was just like yeah total for bad
bad times oh you want to honestly maybe
not a flop we remember it don't we yeah
yeah I remember I guess you're right so
maybe they're like hey it was a success
but they spent a lot of money in
commercials that don't do anything I'll
tell you this right now Pepsi Coke you
want you look look at what Mr Beast did
take your marketing budget for the month
and then just like get a bunch of
homeless people a good meal cleaned up
get them get them help them find you
know jobs help them clip their lives and
then you're gonna get you're gonna get
50 million views yeah you're gonna get
100 million views I mean let me tell you
what would piss you guys off the most is
how much big Pharma agencies probably
get paid to make those generic
commercials where it's just like the
role of people just doing like basic
things like people skipping through
people skipping through a meadow people
going to a bar and they literally make
commercials for drugs like you see it
every single drug commercial just has
like people on random things like people
on a cruise ship and it's a lot of
scooters like going downhills and they
spend millions they spend Millions on
those ads just throwing it down the
drain and it's just like you sort of
think about how much money is wasted
yeah and how it that could actually be
used to pay it forward like this well
and I think about like uh the Ronald
McDonald house that was McDonald's big
initiative to like give people a place
to stay when your kid's in the hospital
and like Wendy's has the Dave Thomas
foundation for adoption like there are
businesses that have philanthropic
efforts but and I'm not saying those two
are perfect examples but like often it's
like look at this thing that we're doing
as opposed to just doing the thing right
like yes Mr Beast made a video of this
yes he made money on the other day hand
like I I don't really follow his content
but like from what I know this is sort
of something he does he regularly tries
to uh help people out like if you had a
pharmaceutical company that just did a
nice thing instead of staging a photo op
like I guess I just don't trust them not
to sort of cheapen the effect right it's
about money and you know Counterpoint to
what you guys are saying you know how
about you know we invest in you know
doing these things you know if you start
making a big deal about you know like
giving away Medical Treatments and stuff
and you're a company that does that
medical treatment which you know
logically that's what you'd be equipped
to give away who's going to buy your
product anymore because they can just
wait for you to give give it for free
like this is what happened in Africa
when we started you know doing all the
food drops you know agriculture stopped
because again everybody was sort of
subsisting off of a lot of food drops
and so we sort of crippled them and
that's just human nature so yeah to a
degree I can see it but I can also see
you know when you start like
de-incentivizing the profit motive can
companies don't invest in you know
researching these treatments to come up
with new ones company you know we can we
can get Pfizer all the crap we want
about what they're doing at the same
time again
if one drug
and I I know this is going to sound
terrible but you know if them making
that money allows them to fund one drug
that can save somebody from a terminal
rare disease
you know it's kind of like well you know
it's evil but you know I kind of it's
It's but you want the other drug yeah
exactly yeah that's hard I mean it
reminds me of like um do you remember
Tom's Shoes
the like oh yeah yeah the economy in
those in those regions yeah but their
whole thing was like if you buy a pair
of shoes from us like you're spending
money but we're giving shoes away right
so like theoretically this sounds good
but there are of course consequences
they destroyed the economy in uh budget
African towns yeah because the Cobblers
all went out of work yeah and couldn't
buy anything everybody had free shoes
but it was you know the the guy who gets
the leather goes to The Cobbler the
cobbler and then makes the shoes and
then buys the leather all of a sudden no
one's buying leather anymore all of a
sudden the guy who who makes the shoes
can't make money now because you can't
make money he's not buying another guy
who gets the leather can't make money he
can't buy food neither can buy food
neither farmer is like I don't have any
money to get the tools I need to make
food and the economy just collapsed each
of these jobs is important because
they're all working for each other
making the machine work and then some
rich people came in and dumped a bunch
of shoes on them no I'm saying like you
know look people who are blind need
surgery I mean that's just giving jobs
to doctors I guess Jimmy actually
pointed out uh is this not even like a
great thing for capitalism in general to
put you know people that were before you
know broken or hurt back into the
workforce now they're healed they're
healthy they're ready to work so that's
a good thing for capitalism as well the
what he was doing technically I don't
know if you'd say it was a capitalist
thing or not it's irrelevant well I mean
everything's charitable right form of
charity for sure yeah but he's made a
ton of money off it with his YouTube ads
and he's doing it for money I mean he's
doing it because he loves people that's
the real reason but he knows that he can
make money off of Charity he started
with his mom when he paid off her
retirement that video went crazy like
he's talking to her and he's like
um he's like get this this will be a
good screenshot for the video mom and
then she's like oh my God Jimmy and he's
like thumbs up what is that wrong like
if you are doing something good but you
make money off it like you benefit
especially when you see I mean he is an
example of how great something like that
can become yeah he's like Oprah yeah you
can get much stuff away and he owns his
own everything let's just still do that
like just like do what because she's
retired now she like does her one
dramatic interview a year dang but I'm
pretty sure it was like the companies
would sponsor giving that stuff away
it's like she was giving it away yeah
that's the thing about me he makes the
money and he gives it away yeah he said
he's going to give all his money away
before he dies and the problem I I think
that's a bad idea of helping to keep it
so the the the I've thought about this
you know like where do you invest and
what charities do you support and that's
why we're working on the the truth and
media one because the issue is I see
these stories like bezos's wife
Mackenzie Bezos gives all that money to
wokeness so these people are like I'm
gonna do good I'm gonna give my money to
Black lives matter and then you're like
buying people mansions not really
solving the problem and I've had
experience with this nonprofit so I just
don't trust them yeah and a lot of
people like I'm gonna give my money away
and I'm like you're gonna flush down the
toilet it's like a Sam bankman freed and
his uh effective altruism and he's
talking about oh how can I give them the
most causes that cause the most good and
then he just donates the Democratic
party because he believes that the
Democrats cause the most good he donated
people's money other people's money yeah
there we go that's the distinction right
and so again somebody he would say oh
that's like Robin Hood then but then you
know it's reverse Robin Hood he's still
it's a chaotic evil you know we got it
Robin Hood thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time